[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
[Musica]
timida dopo
studi sul genere
lascia lo spazio
leggete bene
giocava ansa irrompono cori da stadio
nelle code nazionalismo kafkiana
[Musica]
una nuova
divisa
[Musica]
mi sa bene
di notte sul vostro
ci vorrebbe
[Musica]
brillantino
se tutta la scienza e alla conoscenza
fossero usate per fare bene
terra
e se tutta la scienza
non sei
forse
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ci sei
una piena
[Musica]
la nuova
che dire
[Musica]
[Applauso]
vado via solo su marte
niente fermerà la mia follia
[Musica]
la terra brulla la
sabbia il colore giallo
[Musica]
il vulcano spaziosa un po ancestrale
volo su marte
martedì
facciamola
[Musica]
per strada
lo scoop come una vergine
sole
e
baccanali
dico solo
dicono distesi all'equatore
[Musica]
di note le sirene
colorano il male
[Musica]
grazie
nell'acqua ricordano
[Musica]
magie di una terra brulla sabbia
brulicante
[Musica]
entra sangue come la nava vulcano
già
a disp
[Musica]
nel tempo che bussa piedi scalzi sulle
rocce giallastre
[Musica]
baby
facciamo l'amore
[Musica]
per strada
scoperti
[Musica]
impianti
distesi
motori
siamo
bravo
[Musica]
poco rai alla terra
no
saviano
[Musica]
gira
facciamo
mare
[Musica]
dico
distesi
[Musica]
o
no
[Musica]
riferimento cose o persone è puramente
casuale
non stare a cercarti su cosa ed appare
tante solo casuale tu sei solo casuale
puramente casuale
[Musica]
sicuramente casuale sicuramente casuale
solo casuale
ho letto sul suo cane la notizia di una
guerra del mare religione intanto
muoiono persone
la guerra non è casuale
la materia è tutto interno cambia forma
mentre l'uomo alla distruggersi
distrugge che pagliaccio
riferimento casuale
[Musica]
sicuramente casuale sicuramente casuale
casuale la sua
sicuramente
si è puramente casuale
[Musica]
casualmente che ho incontrato ieri sera
del semaforo rosso
rosso nella
[Musica]
106 sceso dall'auto chi si è rotta la
marchetta così chiesto la mia mamma non
sapevo cosa fare ma qualunque to aiutato
per pensa il caso
guariti non conosco i dettagli ma mi
piace questo vento tra i capelli
pensiero
di restare seduti senza parlare
sicuramente
casuale
la spal è casuale
[Musica]
sicuramente
all
solo così
ci siamo incrociati per
puramente per caso preso la corrente per
sbaglio o
puramente perso
bene
senza
traduzione casuale tu
tutte le mie pagine
sicuro
il caso
casuale
tu se l'equazione per
e la per le minacce di questa
cosa
[Musica]
riferimenti a cose
sicuramente
lasciati aperti su cosa
guardate solo parlare
puramente casuale
[Musica]
attraverso strada deserta
con in mano la
gente che di fretta vorrà il lavoro
sempre il mio tempo
ci vediamo
non mi parli di che cammina
invece vanno incontro con persone e
cravatta
tutti un mese ogni ore presso sono tutti
gli schiavi del sesso
[Musica]
sala
devo alzarmi st
[Musica]
arezzo i tuoi sogni settori ripeto negli
occhi degli altri tuoi aubry ati che
prega messaggio per attaccare bottone
con me
non sempre un segreto in famiglia un
bambino che gioca da solo una scusa
dolente che strilla come minosse che
rinvia caviglia io voglio alzarmi spot e
incontrarti di notte e ballare ballare
ballare
[Musica]
la notte
l'incontro
ansa
se parliamo
no no
tra gli scavi del sud
massei distante in mezzo c'è il mondo ma
ti sento addosso
oltre lo spazio del tempo noi
abbracciamo c
in questa storia so io calo nel vizio
con te che sei addosso
[Musica]
io voglio alzarmi stanotte incontrarti
di notte ballare
belle le sole
[Musica]
incontriamoci accolte ad un party di
notte e balliamo
[Musica]
tutta la notte
io parlo per me
a me piace ballare
non ci credi che
non ci credo che tu come l'ora di
sebastian di tutti quei baci senza
si consolidava seguendo il ritmo con
l'eccezione che io quando parlo parlo
per me
bello per me
[Musica]
per me
[Applauso]
[Musica]
bello per me
grazie mille
grazie
[Applauso]